un estruendoso aplauso resonó en el
salón del pueblo en Beijing la opción
recibió el presidente chino chiquinquin
quien pronunció un discurso de una hora
y media en la inauguración de la edición
número 20 del Congreso comunista del
país el mandatario resaltó algunos de
los puntos de su gestión y defendió
otros de los más criticados como la
política de cero covid que tuvo
detractores incluso dentro del partido
comunista
en particular ante la repentina pandemia
de Kobe 19 nos adherimos a los
principios de las personas primero la
vida primero y también nos adherimos
firmemente a la política dinámica de
cero covid para llevar a cabo la lucha
contra la pandemia
ante 2.300 representantes de todo el
país chilling ping puso en el centro de
la locución a Taiwán y aseguró que
aunque china está a favor de la
reunificación pacífica el presidente
reitero que jamás renunciará al uso de
la fuerza de ser necesaria
ante las actividades sensacionistas de
las fuerzas independentistas de Taiwán y
las graves provocaciones de las fuerzas
externas que se inmiscuyan en los
asuntos de Taiwán
como lanzado decididamente una gran
lucha contra la secesión y la injerencia
demostrando nuestra firme determinación
Y capacidad para salvaguardar la
soberanía nacional y la integridad
territorial y oponernos a la
independencia de Taiwán
otro punto álgido en la agenda Hong
kongping resaltó lo que denominó una
transición del caos a la gobernabilidad
en 2020 el gobierno había implementado
una ley de seguridad nacional Para
calmar los ánimos en el territorio
autónomo que fue fuertemente criticada
por los países occidentales por atentar
contra las libertades el congreso se
prolongará hasta el 22 de octubre y se
espera que sí sea reelecto para un
tercer mandato algo inédito entre sus
predecesores y que afianzaría su poder
en el gigante asiático